at the second conference of the
hydrazone society a paper was presented
that was so revolutionary that members
of the audience did not believe it could
be true
one attendee a respected marine
biologist stated the observation from
the paper was in fact totally impossible
it was an observation made completely by
mistake
in the late 1980s two laboratory
students collected a hydro-zone specimen
that they believed to be turatopsis
nutricula
a tiny jellyfish less than a centimeter
long the individuals they collected were
in their immature adult medusae form
meaning they were not sexually mature
yet and unable to release eggs and sperm
they placed the specimens in a tank
hoping to breed them for research
purposes and forgot all about them
when they returned they expected to find
sexually mature adults
instead they found fewer adult medusas
than when they started and lots of
babies in the form of newly settled
polyps on the bottom of the tank
had these jellyfish reproduced that
quickly
and if they did what happened to all of
the adults
to find out the researchers started to
keep a close watch on the individuals in
the tank
and what they found shocked them
the adult meduse were not spawning and
reproducing to create new baby polyps
they were themselves reverting back into
their juvenile form completely reversing
the aging process what they had
collected was not turatopsis nutricula
but a different jellyfish
turritopsis dornie eye
one they realized is capable of benjamin
buttoning itself over and over again to
the point where scientists learned they
had discovered something inconceivable
immortality
in a world obsessed with aging and
mortality the media went crazy over this
news
what is this tiny jellyfish's secret to
eternal youth can it really live forever
and if it can how might we be able to
harness this age reversing secret for
ourselves
to understand how teratopsis dornii
achieves this amazing feat it's useful
to look at its normal life cycle
the immortal jellyfish is not a true
jellyfish but a hydrozoon that spends
most of its life in its hydroid stage
but for our purposes we will refer to it
by its commonly used jellyfish name
the life cycle of this jellyfish starts
when adult jellyfish in their
recognizable medusae form swarm and
release millions of eggs and sperm
most species of jellyfish will swarm in
the hundreds or even thousands for the
purpose of reproducing
when a sperm successfully fertilizes an
egg the fertilized egg will grow into a
planula a tiny floating larva
within a day or two the planula will
stick to a hard surface like the sea
floor a rock or a coral once stuck
they'll start the next phase
the secured planula starts growing up
from its perch forming a polyp this
looks a bit like a plant a long stem
with a bulbous head which now has a
mouth and long waving fingers
the polyp eats by sucking in food
through its mouth using its tentacles to
help grab it
now the polyps turn into a production
line creating a stack of cloned nearly
jellyfish
when the most mature clone is ready it's
released and floats off into the water
as a tiny version of a jellyfish called
in a phyra
now alone in the ocean all it has to do
is eat and grow and eventually turn into
the medusa we all recognize
and that's the end of the line for most
jellyfish they stay as a medusa swimming
eating and spawning until they die
but turatopsa's dornie eye has a nifty
hack for getting around the slight
inconvenience of death when this tiny
jellyfish experiences high levels of
stress starvation or physical damage it
can send all of its cells back into a
younger state
the jellyfish shrinks and retracts its
tentacles and the medusa turns into a
blobby structure called a cyst that
settles onto the ocean floor just like
its past self
within three days the blobby cyst starts
growing into a polyp and the whole
process starts over
start to finish it can all be done in
about a week
it's like a butterfly turning back into
a caterpillar and if that caterpillar
could then break apart into multiple
butterflies
this amazing process has never actually
been observed in the wild only in the
lab but there's no reason to think it
isn't going on throughout our oceans
so what is going on how does an adult
jelly turn back into a baby
the immortal jellyfish can do this
amazing rejuvenation through a process
called cellular transdifferentiation
this is when a cell of one type turns
into an entirely different type of cell
directly without turning into a neutral
intermediate form first
studies have shown that the medusa
doesn't seem to contain stem cells a
type of cell that has the potential to
be turned into any kind of cell so it
must be the case that its existing cells
are repurposed
scientists have found that the cells of
the top layer of the dome shape of the
medusa and the canal system basically
the jellyfish's digestive system are the
most likely to get turned into new cell
types
of course the cells that make up the
dome of a medusa are different than the
cells that make up a polyp they have
different roles suited to different
needs
it's through trans differentiation that
the immortal jellyfish can get these
specialized medusa cells to turn into
polyp cells this reversal of development
goes against common ideas about aging
across the animal kingdom
it's long been believed that sexual
maturation for any animal marks a point
of no return
that cells are stuck doing what they
will always do
until they reach senescence cell death
but the immortal jelly can turn cells
back into their earlier state at any
point in their life cycle whether
they're a newly produced medusa or an
old timer on the verge of death
all that's needed is a bit of shock in
the first experiments proving this
phenomenon a pinch with some tweezers
was enough to get them to revert
we still don't know exactly how
teratopsis dornii does it but scientists
have had a closer look at the cells of
the cyst form of the immortal jellyfish
and they found some interesting
differences compared to its polyp state
that could tell us how the immortal
jellyfish prepares for its new life
while in its cyst form turatopsa's
dornii spends a good amount of its
energy on internal upkeep in particular
looking after its dna
the jellyfish seems to be able to
protect and repair its telomeres
telomeres are strands of dna found at
the end of chromosomes
and a bit like the plastic bits on our
shoelaces they protect the rest of our
dna from damage especially during cell
replication
every time a cell replicates a little
bit of dna is lost from the telomeres
but because they are extremely long
there is a lot to lose before any of the
important dna is affected
but eventually telomeres are ground down
to nothing and dna is more prone to
damage
this leads to cell death and ultimately
the death of an organism
this is what happens in humans
telomere shortening as it's known is a
key element of aging
but in turatopsis dornii cysts there
seem to be a particularly high number of
genes expressed that promote telomerase
an enzyme that repairs telomeres
with large amounts of this enzyme the
immortal jellyfish could be protecting
the cells from naturally aging by simply
elongating the telomeres and protecting
the jellyfish's dna
on top of this when in its cysts stage
the jellyfish spends little effort on
replication or cell differentiation
which makes sense it's actively trying
to prevent cells from specializing
the cysts also don't respond to external
stimuli ensuring that they are focusing
all of their energy on dna repair and
maintenance until it's ready to become a
polyp once more
this has worked well for turritopsis
dornii it's fast taking over the world's
oceans
originally from the mediterranean it's
believed that they have hitchhiked on
boats and are now found almost
everywhere
their resilience has probably helped
contribute to their ability to survive
across long distances and lots of
environments
researchers have found that in the lab a
single turretopsis dornii is able to
regenerate 10 times at intervals as
short as one month
in the wild this could go on for much
longer possibly forever
in an eternal loop of back and forth
transdifferentiations
it's unlikely that we'll ever be able to
benjamin button ourselves
but there are things we can learn from
this jellyfish that could help us stave
off some of the diseases that plague us
later in life
trans differentiation is an interesting
field for scientists
being able to turn one cell into another
in few to no steps and over a short
period of time could open the doors to
treatments for things like parkinson's
imagine if we could turn skin cells into
neuronal cells to replace lost or
damaged cells in the brain
understanding how the immortal jellyfish
does this could help us work out how to
do it ourselves
another area that the immortal jelly
could shed light on is micro rnas
these are short strands of genetic
material that regulate our dna they can
switch genes on and off and are involved
in dna repair
we know that a lot of dna repair is
happening in a regenerating turretopsis
dornii and finding out more about how
micrornas act to regulate dna repair in
the little jellies could help us do the
same for our own cells
having said that humans and jellyfish
while pretty similar in terms of their
dna when you consider how different we
look still split apart on the tree of
life some time ago and there are genes
and jellyfish that aren't expressed in
humans and vice versa so there may be
some limitations to what is applicable
even though terratopsis dornii was first
discovered in 1883 we only found out it
might be immortal in the 1980s
and we're also learning that there may
be other immortal creatures out there
the natural world from organisms large
and small from jellies to trees to
microbes to fungi likely hold answers
that we can't even conceive of right now
but as we discover more biodiversity and
as our scientific technology becomes
increasingly sophisticated we are likely
to find out more and it may mean new
avenues for treatments for degenerative
diseases and cancer
while the immortal jellyfish may not
hold the answer to a never-ending life
for us
it may at least give us a little longer
to fill our increasingly long lives it's
important to continuously fill our minds
and if you're like me entertaining but
educational documentaries are one of the
best ways to fill both
youtube can be a treasure trove of
content and finding a bingeable channel
or series that is also educational is
one of the greatest feelings
one of the worst feelings is when you're
out of ideas of what to watch especially
when you have your lunch sitting in
front of you and you can't eat it until
you find something good this happens to
me when i've already seen nearly all the
videos made by my favorite creators if
you've ever felt this lack of content
induced despair now is the best time
ever to sign up to nebula the streaming
platform me and several other
educational content creators made
together which is a gold mine of new
original content
to dive deep into history the brand new
series battle of britain made by the
team behind this channel and real
engineering is of such high quality i
can't believe it's not made for tv
it's a series that will take you through
the key moments of the first major
military campaign fought entirely by air
forces the 3d animations are out of this
world and the storytelling will leave
you captivated all while learning about
one of the most important moments in
modern history
there are so many original series like
this on nebula with more coming in all
the time and right now is the single
best time to sign up nebula has
partnered with curiositystream to offer
you both streaming services for just
11.59 for the entire year that's 42
percent off the usual price meaning you
get both services for less than a dollar
per month and with this subscription you
are also supporting us in the best way
possible
every sign up helps us to hire more
animators take on bigger projects and
keep the lights on and the machines
running so go to curiositystream.com
real science to get both nebula and
curiosity stream for just 11 59 for the
entire year and if you're looking for
something else to watch right now you
can watch our previous video about the
incredible harpy eagle or watch real
engineering's latest video about the
unusual fuel spacex is exploring for its
upcoming missions